you've had so many fantastic things on
the go recently films and TV shows we've
got many more coming up - of course
we've had a shock exit from Mad Men this
year haven't we how did you learn about
that were you shocked as we all were I
was he told me after episode 10 the
read-through of episode 10 and he he
likes to talk to people after the
read-through because this is Matthew I
know because he's not able to come on
set that often because he's writing the
other episodes so I could see he was
leaving me for last and after everyone
had gone he said let's go up to my
office as a bad sign
and he's a he's a fantastically erudite
person and the second sign was waiting
for the lift and he got slightly
tongue-tied and started making small
talk which he never ever does he's
always the most sort of the most sort of
passionate and had a tenth of intensely
focused man and then when we get to his
office he says would you like a brandy
you get the really good stuff as well
yeah he did yes
he said we should pickle our livers
after we drink this would that be worth
more than us
but and I wasn't shocked there I was
disappointed but I wasn't shocked
because they'd been little you know
there's been a feeling around bass hand
that someone someone might be thrown
overboard now another character of yours
who were not quite sure so what's
happened to you in Sherlock Holmes - we
you had Moriarty didn't you he was very
well received now I'm wondering whether
he might come back with Sherlock Holmes
three-d-- what do you think would you
like to come back did he be saved
they haven't talked to me about I have
no idea and I would love to this because
I had a great fun great time working
with Robert and going but I have no idea
I'm not involved but those conversations
happens way above my pay grade that's me
Joel and guy and Robert and
Susan will be figuring out what the next
story will be I mean I guess I could
have survived but but as far as I know
at the moment I haven't yeah Moriarty
had a brother that was an odd thing that
mrs. Moriarty named both her sons that
James Moriarty so yeah army I think but
I've no idea I mean you can do anything
with us if they want to well if you
could do anything what would you like to
see happen in what in Sherlock Holmes
through that one feed that mill I mean
you know as far as I know I at the
moment nothing so but we know we have
got coming up is of course the Mortal
Instruments City of Bones which it looks
like it could be lining it to be an
absolutely enormous series of films how
do you feel about your role and that
tell me a bit about it it was good fun
you know I it was it was a it was a
little strange being the sort of the
older wiser sage character with all the
kids but you know it was it was good
that those they're just huge machines
those films you know and you sort of
slot into a very specific role but I got
to do some I got to have some good fun I
got to do some ass-kicking
which was nice and good we also have us
another thing I did a movie for hammer
yeah it's and this is a supernatural
thriller it's a British movie
appropriate to mention it
and what kind of role you're taking in
that a slightly crazed professor who's
trying to who creates an experiment to
try and see if he can recreate a
poltergeist
you